[Music]
well welcome back to another episode of
the addie hour as always it's my honor
and pleasure to host these conversations
today i'm thrilled to be able to host
juju chang for our conversation on
society
culture and being a voice for
marginalized communities so this is a
name that's probably familiar to all of
you as listeners but i'm going to go
ahead and give you just a little bit of
an introduction so as you all likely
know juju chang is an emmy award-winning
co-anchor of abc news nightline she also
reports regularly for good morning
america and 2020.
recently her decades of reporting
converged in a way as she hosted two
hour long specials about the rise of
hate crimes towards asian american and
pacific islander communities in 2021 so
very important work
she's someone who's been recognized for
her in-depth personal narratives that
have been set against a backdrop of
pressing national and international news
from natural disasters to terrorism and
racial equity just to highlight a few of
the stories that she has covered one was
a critical examination of the
controversial
remain in mexico immigration policy
her award-winning report trans and
targeted on violence against transgender
women of color across the country and
also her extensive coverage of the coven
19 pandemic the science the economic
fallout the racial disparities the
impact on hospital icus and essential
workers
juju is someone who has profiled
numerous newsmakers over the years too
many to list here but many who are
influential in lots of different spheres
and i also want to mention she's a
member of
the council on foreign relations and a
founding member of the board of korean
american community foundation so someone
who's also been invested in a lot of
different ways so again i'm grateful to
be able to welcome juju jujutang to the
idr podcast thanks for being here
i am so pleased to join you today
excellent wonderful to have you here and
again so many important things that you
have done which we'll touch on as we go
through the episode but as my listeners
know and one of the things i think my
listeners appreciate is just the chance
for us to be able to peel back the
layers as it were so i wanted to start
with just a general check-in and see how
you're doing at this point in time at
the end of april 2022 with everything
that we're continuing to navigate how
are you doing at this this point in time
it's so um profoundly
lovely of you to do that and do a mental
health check-in um i'm okay right now um
it was rough going through the
anniversary of the atlanta shootings um
i went back to atlanta and talked to
um victims families uh one year later
and you know you tend to absorb a lot of
the traumatic stories when you know um
you're in my line of work and there's
something called empathy trauma right
i've talked to sex crimes prosecutors
who have it and and i've gone from you
know chasing boko haram in
africa to the pulse nightclub shooting
and trying to just power through and be
a good journalist and don't you know
just compact compact compact and then
bursting into tears you know at
the drugstore um right now i'm okay i've
done a lot of you know everything from
therapy to giggling with my girlfriends
to meditation but i will say
that um some of my african-american
colleagues did mental health check-ins
with me when at the height of the aapi
um
uh hate and i
was it was a little bit unexpected so i
literally started tearing up and and
what everything that i had held back
kind of poured out in 30 seconds and
then immediately i felt guilty because
for these same african-american
colleagues
i didn't do a mental health check-in you
know to say i know that this hurts to
watch members of your community i know
that this hurts to have to explain you
know i know
and and just that simple
check-in meant so much to me i just
assumed that my colleagues knew how i
felt about
their struggle and the pain their pain
but i had never
expressed it before so i'm not only
grateful to you but i would encourage
all of us to to do check-ins with our
our friends and colleagues and loved
ones yeah so important and so well said
and i'm just impressed thankful for your
level of candor and impressed at the
process that you even went through of
letting all those emotions out but also
kind of catching what was happening in
the midst of that
as well um and something that was
actually going to tie back into and just
thinking about you know the emotional
toll of the type of the work
that you do i mean it sounds like that
in itself may have been a journey in the
way that you let things out all that
moment i wonder
if you've thought back about how you had
been processing a lot of the different
things that you've been walking through
up to that point and if that was a shift
yes i think it has been a shift in um
in that sometimes like as a journalist
or maybe as a community activist or as a
uh advocate you feel like you're doing
something right and that goes a long way
to helping you feel feel
overwhelmed or helpless in the face of
darkness honestly um but what i found is
that when i was in
you know chad cameroon in nigeria
following the trail of boko haram i was
talking to young girls who had
literally watched their whole families
be slaughtered in front of them who were
you know kidnapped um held as sex slaves
just you know but they were talking to
me with a flat affect right
and
you could just see the trauma all over
them
um and for some reason you're
as an american you're kind of an arm's
length away from not really
understanding what it's like to have
your village burned down and to have
your livestock slaughter you know
it's just a different
life and but i came back to the states
and literally within 10 days was uh in
orlando outside the pulse nightclub
and and interviewing a family who had
gone there on vacation and happened to
be an african-american family but they
googled best nightclub in orlando and
they ended up at pulse
and when i went to the home
i'm i'm seeing the aunties like cooking
dinner for the children who are
completely traumatized by this you know
and for some reason i connected to their
family more
um more viscerally and i just
found that the cumulative traumatic
stories was having an impact on me i
could feel it and yet i kept holding it
back and you know these these young
women were describing watching the
gunman in front of them walk back and
forth and one looked her straight in the
eye and she played dead i mean
the presence of mind i don't even know
and and that's a trauma that she'll be
processing for the rest of her life
right and so there are so many occasions
where i talk to people and and
and
uh hear their stories but
in a similar vein i was in um las vegas
with the vegas nightclub shooting and
you'll recall that was the one where
there was a shooter on the 32nd floor
and he had
you know
luggage case after luggage case full of
ammunition shooting down onto the
concert and i was interviewing a young
woman who was in the hospital the next
day and she said we heard shots run out
i was with my parents it was just the
three of us and i started running
running running running until i realized
my pants were wet and i looked down i
thought that's blood
and she'd been shot and ran a quarter of
a mile with a bullet lodged in her hip
and she said but immediately out of
nowhere i collapsed and a complete
stranger an off-duty firefighter came
and started shielding me from the
bullets and administering first aid and
then somebody else came over with a
makeshift gurney one of those like
concert gates and the next day when i
interviewed the hospital workers they
were like
there were so many people volunteers
dragging victims to the hospital and in
the hospital room the woman with the
bullet lodged still in her hip said to
me you know what i saw i saw one bad man
in the tower and hundreds of heroes here
on the ground and she was like i am so
grateful wow and i thought
in the face of all of that darkness
you know you you you see
goodness and you see hope um and so that
is what i cling to when i tell these
stories right of of such darkness and
depravity
that's such a helpful perspective too as
as as i imagine as you're going through
all these different components and
walking through with people and it's so
helpful how she shared that because even
as you were telling the story i was
thinking oh you're seeing the hope in
the midst of that the hope and the
humanity in people but the to hear her
put that in context of one versus a
hundred i think is so powerful
totally totally and i quote her to this
day it's been years and i was so such a
powerful moment
yeah really really important and i
imagine things like that just keep you
going um but to step back even a little
bit further and to give our listeners
again a peek back i'm curious if you'd
be willing to share just how you even
got into this path in the first place
what motivated you
to get into reporting into journalism
into co-anchoring and to bringing these
stories these important stories to such
a larger audiences the way that you have
so effectively well two things my joke
is that i basically failed freshman
calculus
so um you know there are a lot of i've
had feedback on this like don't you know
buy into these rumors that you know
these stereotypes that women aren't good
at math i was like oh no that's not the
stereotype i'm breaking the stereotype
that asians are good at math um so i
feel like you know
you're safe but
yeah exactly
but i you know but like my well-meaning
immigrant parents wanted me to be an
engineer right so that's what i was
gonna do at you know i was a freshman at
stanford and i took a required class in
political science not because i wanted
to but because i had to and i ended up
getting an a plus in that class at the
same time that i got a 27 out of 100 in
calculus and i thought huh
i feel like the universe is trying to
tell me something
and
that combined with the fact that
you know
i think
we talk about how representation matters
and role models matter at the time
connie chung was a prominent
asian-american broadcaster
and my mother was the one who said to me
you know that
that connie chung you could be like her
and it was that moment like that's why
role models are so important is because
role models give you permission to dream
and that's what happened and it it
allowed me for the first time to go
against sort of what my family my
culture
everyone around me was saying that i
should do
um and then thirdly i think part of the
reason why and i really have only
thought about this more recently but
part of the reason why i think i've
always been drawn to stories of
marginalized communities and and and the
underdog and you know the powerless is
that that's the way i grew up right i
grew up you know an immigrant child from
korea i was born in korea came to the
northern california when i was four
and felt very much like an outsider like
it was silicon valley before it was
silicon valley right so
it was uh
cherry orchards and apricot trees and
there was no some advanced micro devices
right and
and i went to school thinking that my
family talked funny and my family's food
smelled funny and i was told on the
playground a lot that my face looked
funny in fact i tell the story that i
used to go to sleep at night with scotch
tape on my nose because i wanted to wake
up and look like a california girl with
like not a flat nose
um so
i
watched my father be treated
poorly
um and i didn't have words to describe
what i was witnessing right like today
you would call it racism or
microaggression or whatever but at the
time i was a young girl and i just knew
that it wasn't right right and i knew
that it didn't feel right
and i didn't like it and i still i think
i spent the next 30 years
seeing the world through the eyes of
that young girl right who felt
marginalized who felt other who
understood what it means to be
dismissed or invisible or all those
things that happened to marginalized
communities and so
you know that's part of why i'm drawn to
stories on the border you mentioned the
story about remain in mexico you know i
went did stories about pregnant mothers
bringing young children and their unborn
babies you know to a better place right
which is essentially what happened to me
right at the age of four so i'm seeing
like four-year-old kids and i'm relating
to them in a totally different way
um
it's why i went to honduras and did a
whole series on femicide why why
honduras was one of the most dangerous
places to be a woman and explored why
um you know violence against women is
often you know sexualized it's often
intimate partner violence it's often
violence that involves rampant guns and
lack of accountability
and those are all things that happen in
societies at different levels right and
so it was a really it was
they call it femicide you know women
would disappear and that no one would be
held accountable and so it's you know
there are so many stories where i look
back and i realize i'm drawn to them
because i'm drawn to telling the stories
of the little guy
that's really really powerful the way
you said that was there a point that you
feel like you were able to start to
verbalize that so i'm gonna i'm gonna
assume that as a four-year-old probably
not but there may have been a path along
the way because even as you're talking
back through it
it seems like you can clearly pick out
specific instances and situations that
shaped how you look at things but was
the point where you became more aware of
it
and that you were able to verbalize that
and translate that into what you were
actually doing
i think it took a really long time i'm a
little thick in the head i guess i just
it didn't i wasn't um
i was more
early on interested in um
making my way in the world right and so
i wasn't about my identity like i think
that's the big change frankly for me
i was part of you know the shift in
thinking um
after george floyd's murder right i just
feel like i took inspiration from my
african-american colleagues who in that
moment for the first time you know
pierre thomas like stevens and sami some
of my closest friends and colleagues at
abc news who i've known for 30 years
who've never talked about their
upbringing their lived experience into
their reporting they started
giving the rest of the world insights
into what it's like to be a black man
driving home from work and being pulled
over right and
so i
started
doing that a bit in my
you know reporting especially with
regard obviously to aap i hate right to
talk about let me give you some
perspective because i had done that in
other areas right so like if i was doing
a story about parenting or mommy you
know mommy angst i would bring my
experience as a mom into the story like
what that would be nothing but a net
gain right so i realized that
really pretty late in life that that's
what
my value added was in a funny way right
and so i had founded this korean
american community foundation which
we're about to have our gala we raised
you know two million dollars last year
blossomed into this huge undertaking but
it was always something i did
off-camera outside of work and now i've
brought my understanding and my identity
more central and and that has been a
shift for me that
i i don't know
honestly if i can put pinpoint you know
when that happened but it was a slow
burn for sure
that's really helpful to know and just
to see your process and journey in that
as well i mean even to be honest some
conversations i was having today even in
terms of parallels between the
african-american community the aapi
community and the things that people are
walking through but as you've mentioned
it seems like the conversation is
shifting
in the sense that there's more openness
to speak about those things across
groups and to have some aspects of
similarity and this is a fresh thought
i'm still formulate but one thing i've
also noticed is there seems to be
some commonalities that were there that
people are more able to talk about in
the ways that others aren't so i've even
had members you know within academic
settings from aapi communities who have
talked about sometimes those outside
their community who don't know how to
enter into that conversation because
they think they're going to say
something wrong or they're worried about
missteps whereas with african-americans
they don't have that same type of
hesitation because there is
a mutual
experience and language so to speak even
though it's not the same experience but
there are so many overlapping
components that people seem to be
sharing
across the communities again this is a
new thought so it's not quite it's not
coming out as clearly as it is in my
head but just something i'm starting to
notice over time so i don't know if
that's been your experience as well but
yeah i i think it's really important for
us to be able to have these
um conversations in
and and not be afraid of offending each
other because
that fear
just nips the conversation in the bud
before it even happens so
an example that i often give is um i
interviewed a non-binary actor by the
name of nico tortorelli and i sat down
with them and i said
i'm really sorry if i misgender you if i
use the wrong pronoun i don't you know
and he they said to me see they said to
me
juju it's totally fine i understand that
you're trying and that you know your
intentions are good it really does
matter like where it comes from if
somebody misgenders me with hate then
that's not okay but if somebody
misgenders me by accident in
conversation i'm not going to take
offense to that um and so i think that
is the
the spirit in which these conversations
need to happen we have to have that hold
that grace between
you know the person who's speaking and
the person who's listening and i think
you know we talked about jeremy lin and
one of the most
i think uh classy ways that he discussed
um a a microaggression or a a a slur
that happened to him on court right with
somebody somebody on court
called him the coronavirus or called
them china virus or something and and
afterwards everybody you know the
reporters nosy reporters like me
were like at the press conference saying
so who did it who did it
and and he said you know i have no
interest in shaming or blaming anyone
but i want to call out the behavior
because if i don't then it's then it's
seen as okay and i thought that is
such a great way of looking at these
conversations because you know we can't
learn unless we have these conversations
and we don't and yet at the same time we
don't want to be
um just you know
calling balls and strikes all the time
and and you know telling people you know
that what they said was wrong or hurtful
or stupid or worse right yeah yeah
that's so so all said and even that word
grace that came up as you were talking
to that individual i think is huge just
to have the grace to be able to make
those mistakes and it seems there's also
a level of trust there that needs to be
there trust that the people are coming
from the right place of intentionality
and again just having that place to have
to have that learning because as you
said if the mistakes don't happen then
people won't learn and perhaps that's
again my neuroscience piece that's
coming out already but that's just what
we learned from those types of things
and how that also
needs to be applied in these situations
as well
absolutely absolutely
on that no i also was curious just about
because you i mean again you've done i
keep going back to but just so much that
you've done to really have and speak for
so many marginalized and quote-unquote
voiceless communities not that they have
a voice but not to the level that they
need to and i'm curious you know as
you've been doing this over the years
are there specific aspects of your work
that have been both the most rewarding
and on the other side the most
challenging
so i'll let you start with whichever one
of those
oh
so hard um the most rewarding one i
think was
um at the atlanta
shooting uh more than a year ago um
because
we were the abc news was the only one
only network who did a full prime time
hour
following that shooting and i know
that that wouldn't have happened were it
not for the years and months of work
that i had done
um you know
pre-interviewing people doing interviews
with activists having everything sort of
locked and loaded so that we could air
it within 24 hours i remember flying
down there and we had booked you know
the son of one um victim and the
daughter of another victim and i was
like so angry because i was like you
know once again you know we have to
crash this to the air and you know we
don't have time to do it i can't believe
we have to do this in 48 hours and i
thought
actually it is in 48 hours i i've been
working steadily
um towards telling this particular story
for 30 years because
you know how many mass shootings have i
been to and and delicately had to speak
to a family member how many stories have
i done on human trafficking and sex work
and what that really means in a true
sense um and and and the geopolitics of
it and the
poverty and the deprivation and the
desperation um surrounding it and how
many of these you know stories about aap
i hate have i done and so all of that
felt like it was a true culmination and
so that was the story that i was most
proud of and we were able to really get
at
one of the
fundamental sort of um areas that that
it is dicey which is the
hypersexualization of asian women and
you know you'll recall there was a
county sheriff who came out after
speaking to the shooter and saying well
shooter says
you know he has a sex addiction and he
was trying to get rid of his sex
addiction so he says it wasn't about
race
it was about sex
at which point asian american activists
came out um very
uh united in their um
opposition to that idea right this idea
that you know the shooter drove 25 plus
miles past strip clubs and porn shops
and other you know sex work and went to
three different asian themed spas and
conflated any asian woman in there
um as a sex worker and that is
racialized at the very least
according to so many of the experts that
i spoke to so it was a galvanizing
moment in the um asian american
community i interviewed two as i say two
victims children one was a chinese woman
immigrant
and she told the story about her mother
who'd come here with nothing from a
rural province in china who had worked
you know after hours to get a massage
license scraped together pennies worked
six days a week ate from the rice you
know the rice maker in the back so she
could save even more money so she could
open her own spa and she had signs in
every room that said no sex no you know
hanky-panky and all of her friends said
anytime anybody asked for that kind of
stuff they called the police and she was
very very angry right about that
conflation
now the flip side of it is i interviewed
a young man whose mother worked in a
different spa and his name is randall
park and he said to me randy park and he
said you know i
i was told when i was when my mom when i
was growing up that my mom worked in a
beauty salon
and but when i got older
i understand that i understood that it
was shady that was the
words that he used and he went and um
confronted his mother
and i asked
him what that conversation was like and
he said you know um would you tell your
son
if you worked in a
you know spa like that
and of course he's like about the age of
my son and i
literally stopped short and i you know i
i knew what i would say but i told him
i'm a journal you know a journalist and
so i said to him
that's a really good question
and he went on to say i told my mother
let's not tell my little brother he said
but i want you to be safe
i don't like that you lied to me
um and and in closing in the same
conversation this 21 year old young man
said to his mother i will never shame
you for the decisions that you made
because i know how hard you worked to
make sure that
me and my brother as a single mom
were okay
um and i was just blown away by him and
he had given up
interviews like this and he went on
gofundme and he asked for a little
funeral expenses help you know like we
live hand-to-mouth we i don't want to
lose this you know little apartment that
we have maybe you could just help me
with some funeral expenses and within 72
hours he raised more than 1.7 million
dollars
and if you go online now and you go fund
me randy park he's closer to 3 million
and i of course was like what in the
world is happening and so i scrolled
through all of the gofundme and it was
exactly what i said this idea that it
had this galvanizing impact right that
so many of the donations they weren't
big dollar donations they were like 25
75 50 and the notes and the expressions
were very similar they were like
we're really sorry for your loss randy
we see your pain randy
my mother sacrificed like your mother
and i'm so sorry for your loss you know
um on and on and on of really just being
seen
right and and and that struggle that
immigrant struggle and sacrifice was
really visible um and so we were really
proud to be able to tell that story and
we went back one year later
told you know gave updates on a number
of the victims
um and and it was an incredibly powerful
amount of storytelling um
so
so that was one that i'm most proud of
in terms of the ones that i've found
most difficult is you know um
i have watched um
our community the asian american
community um be
um
held up as the quote-unquote model
minority which is as you know such
mythology it's such a you know
out-and-out falsehood because you know
again i founded the korean american
community foundation predicated on the
fact that there's an 18 poverty rate for
asian americans in the tri-state area
right
one in every four korean americans in
northern new jersey is uninsured
many are undocumented many struggle um
and yet they're invisible right i mean
these are the these are the asians that
are not the crazy rich asians that
everyone thinks you know ends up at yale
right they're the they're the they're
the asians who bring you chinese food
dinner or
you know polish your nails in the nail
salon or give you gas at the
gas station or sell you liquor in the
you know you know or the dry cleaning or
whatever and these are invisible um
their struggle and their pain is often
invisible and i think
for me
um it's been difficult to watch our
community and you know it's hard because
it's like oh it's a good stereotype why
would you not like that it's like well
not only does it put undue pressure on
those in the community you know i'm sure
you see it among your asian american
students
but it also
for those who don't fit that stereotype
is it's really negative and then that
stereotype is used to pit our community
against other communities of color and
so that is another sort of pain point
you know uh for our community and it's
it's it's led to so much
misunderstanding and
um
you know at a time when we should be
working in solidarity on
mutual you know um
you know we have we should all band
together to fight hate period full stop
um
white allies hispanic allies
african-american allies we should all be
allied together and so
to me it's been painful to to watch some
of those you know those stories emerge
really well said i mean so many things
that resonate and so much
to unpack as well one thing that i want
to actually go back to in the first you
know the first story that you were
sharing about about this being a
galvanizing moment because again you
know having had a lot of i've had korean
american roommates in college a lot of
other asian american friends and just
thinking about things that have been
happening over the years
that have not come to the surface so to
speak i mean even when you were talking
about the tragedy in atlanta how your
network was the only network to do what
you did and so i'm wondering how
how that has been affecting the asian
american community already
up to this point and what you see
as a shift because even as you talked
about you have been preparing that story
for years not just because of the work
you've been doing around anti-asian hate
but because of the work you've been
doing around
marginalization and discrimination in
general but again it just seems like so
much of it has been as you said under
the surface and so
are things how do you see things
shifting are there things that are
moving
there are i see
yeah i mean i see a lot of change in the
last two years um i think i started
seeing it
um
you know in the black lives matter
protest right when i because you know as
a journalist i was out covering those
protests
um you know face to you know police
shield in the middle of the
masked protests but when i looked around
i had covered many protests in my
30-year career but these protesters
looked more like america you know they
were
parents and children protesting
grandparents you know the black
community obviously the latino community
i had never seen so many asian americans
protesting
um and for black lives matter and i
thought that was such a like a an
awakening right and in many ways
tool gathering if you know what i'm
saying um
and
it really
to me
opened people's um hearts and minds i
think and then when the aapi hate stuff
started happening
um
i really felt like i saw
a maturation right so the points of
light to me are the young activists who
are going to the alders and saying you
know what mom dad grandpa
you're vulnerable and you can't stick
with the cultural norms of keep your
head down don't say anything don't raise
ruckus right you need to go and report
this you need to go and make your rides
better and i heard somebody a young
comedian on tick tock my kids hate it
when i mentioned tick tock but he said
he was a i think he was a south asian he
said you know
my family called it the uncle sam tax
you know that we were
they were
willing to be treated like second-class
citizens because of the bounty that this
country offers right and he said but my
generation we're not willing to do that
we
we all took you know his ap history and
political science and we have the
audacity to believe that we deserve
equal protection under the law that we
deserve equal rights that we therefore
are americans and it was such a powerful
you know kind of rallying cry for a
comedian
really lovely
um but i think that's kind of what i'm
seeing in the young generation i also
think that i'm seeing
you know jonathan greenblatt of the adl
yeah the anti-defamation league runs the
center for hate and he saw a lot of the
online hate spiking and he went to the
asian american community and and warned
them and that is how the asian american
foundation was
um created and it was launched by very
um
sort of powerful um philanthropists um
including like josiah joe bay josiah who
owns the nets joe bay you know all these
jerry yang you know like all these very
high profile um people who leveraged
their
considerable power and wealth and
founded the asian american foundation to
help
you know again this was this galvanizing
moment that that happened so i think
that you know and then i see like
grassroots community organizers you know
people who are in chinatown who are like
young kids who are like you know doing
stuff and in georgia
there was a big get out the vote
you know sort of enrollment um and and
we're told by activists that that was
the
crucial margin for the two senate races
in georgia and um and so you know i've
seen
asian american
organizations over the years
do like oh let's ask for bilingual
ballots let's look for more ballot
access let's do this kind of stuff that
literally the work of democracy and i
think that that has accelerated um
because of this so you know uh there are
points of light so to speak yeah that's
really encouraging to hear i mean just
in the way that some of those
organizations have come to light
and the way that people have been
invested in that work as well and it's
so important
and of course i'm always again you know
thinking about the neuroscience and
mental health i'm always just thinking
about just the tax as it were of all
these things on the asian american
community and so i wonder if you'd be
wanting to share a little bit first
about just your perceptions about mental
health conversations in aapi communities
and how that
intersects in a way with all that's
happened around anti-aging aid how that
can
also influence that and just if things
are moving in terms of conversation we
had a little bit of that conversation a
couple episodes ago with um jeremy lin
as you mentioned esther too but just
curious to hear your perspective on that
as well
well i think there are
many different directions to
you know turn the telescope i mean
there's the idea that asian american
young people are often um suffering
higher rates of anxiety and
stress and depression um because i think
of the sort of
pressure of living up to the model
minority myth often when your parents
when your parents have sacrificed
everything for you
that's a lot of pressure you don't want
to screw that up right and you feel very
burdened by that at the same time
the asian american community is very i
mean i hate to speak broadly because we
know the asian-american community
represents dozens of countries and even
more cultures and languages and you know
faith traditions and all of that but
but
if i were to say culturally asian
americans uh there's a very big stigma
uh uh
about mental surrounding mental health
so there's a lot of open discussion
there's a lot of
you know therapy treatment options there
isn't a lot in that space and and then
thirdly i would say
when you drill down into these attacks
many of them involve a component of a
mental health break on the part of the
perpetrators right and we've seen that
time and time again whether it's you
know somebody who walks into a black
church and and kills parishioners
whether it's somebody who walks into a
jewish synagogue and kills parishioners
or somebody who walks into three asian
themed spas and kills
asian americans and and bystanders
you see this is this is disordered
behavior right this is mental illness
and
um and yet a lot of this
is
reframed depending on
the circumstances right and i think that
ultimately that is why dog whistles are
so dangerous right it's not because
rational people are going to go out and
attack asian people it's because you
know because of the pandemic it's
because irrational people may right and
there's a lot of intersection of
poverty and
homelessness and mental health crises
and
and so
the solutions are
very complicated
and
uh complex and multi-layered and they
are not nothing's quick there's no quick
answers and so people who are like oh
let's you know the other thing that's
tricky is that some of this flies into
the face of the defund
debate right because there are those who
argue well we need more policing we need
stronger police presence police force
right and then there are others who say
no this is exactly why we need more
mental health
um we need more culturally competent
police officers who can speak the
different asian languages and be
culturally competent so that if somebody
is victimized they're not afraid to go
to the police because in the old country
you didn't go to the police right that
kind of stuff how do you how do you get
a hate crimes charge when the witnesses
or the victim don't speak the language
or not well enough to come up right so
there are so many complexities
that need to be
examined unfortunately
we don't have a very
patient you know polit political body
and so you know these very nuanced
solutions and complicated solutions are
are hard to get at to say the very least
and i think you know but i do think that
it's
you know from a mental health
perspective from a neuroscience
perspective
so much of what we've
endured as a society during the pandemic
is flaring out
i'm sure you would agree in so many
different spheres and so
um you know you're seeing this giant
uptick in gun violence you're seeing a
giant uptick in violent crime you're
seeing an uptick in self-harm you're
seeing an uptick in all of these
um
mental health arenas that again are
often reframed you know and so hate
crimes are sadly among them
yeah and there's so many as you
mentioned so many things that we have to
pay attention to on so many different
scales i mean even thinking you know
going back to childhood think about what
needs to happen in the schools
because as students are going through
everything as parents are going through
all that as those combine together all
the anxieties uncertainties that people
are navigating simultaneously in certain
situations as you add on top of that all
the things like the stories that you've
been covering for years they're just
going to become that much more
exacerbated so i think i think you're
exactly right in that component and yet
at the same time even as you mentioned
early on you still see these
aspects and these reasons for hope
um so even in the midst of that it seems
that there's still something that keeps
you going one and talking about these
stories but then seeing the hope that
people are
having to move forward as things have
been galvanized in a sense and i'm just
curious what you know what gives you
hope on a day-to-day basis because i'm
thinking about being in your shoes
and just walking into certain situations
how heavy
that must be and how do you enter into
that space
and how do you exit out of that space to
still have hope for the future going
forward
yeah it's it's a great question and i i
um
i've tried meditation i'm a lousy
meditator um but i it's good to know
thank you i try i try but um
i i
there's a form of loving kindness
meditation where you're supposed to you
know meditate and spread loving kindness
you know whatever but you start
by sending loving-kindness to yourself
right and i think that that we we beat
ourselves up we're so hard on ourselves
we're so mean to ourselves i think that
is a big part of how i try to you know
lift myself up um but i want to i want
to share a story about one victim i
interviewed her name was velma carey
filipina american and they she was
beaten up in front of a midtown high
rise and the highlight of her beating
was that the
um lobby folks were seen closing the
door as this beating was happening and
later the the building said you know you
only saw a part of the clip you didn't
see all of it but the bottom line was it
created a lot of you know um uh
awareness on her particular attack and
so
it took us weeks but we finally
convinced her daughter and her to sit
down for an interview and they did such
powerful
stuff so they had two had done a
gofundme they raised a couple hundred
thousand dollars which was significant
and and the daughter um
took that money and created a pop-up uh
museum with with um
stories so what happened was during the
attack the attacker just again to bring
some humanity to the attacker he was
having a mental health break he was just
let out of prison for killing his own
mother so
you know there was a tremendous amount
of um
trauma there
and he
beat up this random woman and said you
asian
b word you know you don't belong here
and so the daughter took these stories
of belonging from the aapi community
and created exhibits using these words
and and
entitled it aap i belong
and so and so then i'm sitting down with
vilma and her daughter and vilma says i
said so did you ever make it to st
patrick's cathedral because i heard that
was where you were headed that day and
she said yes i did i went for my 60th
birthday i said what did you pray for
and she just had this big smile on her
face and she said i prayers of gratitude
she said i we had so much
loving
pouring out pouring of food people were
sending food and gifts and notes of
encouragement and money in the gofundme
and i couldn't believe like how much
people showed their compassion to me and
then she looked at her daughter and she
looked at me and she said and then
i prayed for my attacker
and literally the camera on me at the
moment was like this
and i said wow
why did you do that and she said because
whatever was going on in his mind
i wanted to give him grace
that was literally the words that she is
and i sat there for a second and i said
to her you know
again i've been doing this for 30 years
and i've talked to a lot of people about
a lot of things and i said but i know
enough whether you look at it from the
neuroscience perspective
or from the spiritual perspective or
from the
psychology you know uh philosophical
perspective that like that act
of forgiving someone
does as much if not more to empower the
person who's doing the forgiving
then it does
bestow on the person who's being
forgiven and
so in that moment i said to her you know
what's really crazy vilma is that you're
literally fighting hate
with love yeah and and it was just such
a powerful moment for me and i thought
it was so obviously so genuine from her
sort of catholic
you know perspective and
um and so that's the kind of stuff that
that gives me hope that like makes me
think that
we can turn
this
you know a hateful act into a piece of
art you know aap i belong to turn
victimization into something more
powerful and meaningful and then to take
this incident and
and surround it with
meaning
wow that's so beautiful
so well crazy right i know she was so
powerful yeah and you also you took the
words out of my mouth in terms of that
holistic approach to things as well
because i mean that's so much of what we
talk about on this podcast thinking
about all those different perspectives
whether like you said neuroscience the
spiritual component the psychological
component and how all these things
intersect and so i think that's just a
beautiful encapsulation of all that and
it's so important i mean i'm trying not
to pull in all the neuroscience but what
that does all those components what
those do to our brains and how that
helps us to come up with different
coping strategies and to move through um
even in our last conversation we had a
conversation with a psychiatrist who
also is a man of faith and talked about
all the evidence for the spiritual
practices when they are tied together
with different psychological
interventions and how powerful that can
be and it seems like even that's even
that's not your profession how you've
seen that at work in so many different
ways that's really
really powerful and really encouraging
to hear about as well
the one piece i was also going to ask
about as we wrap up is just your i know
this may feel a little bit um
like i'm pulling it back in but just
thinking about your faith walk as well
as you are someone who grew up in a
korean-american household but then also
converted to judaism at one point and so
as you know as we brought that part into
the conversation curious how that
journey came about and how that has also
impacted your outlook on all the work
that you do
you know i was the reluctant jew
[Music]
i've actually never used that phrase but
i i think it's true you know i married a
nice jewish guy
named neil shapiro and uh i told him
when we were dating and after we got
married um that i was never gonna
convert so like
end of topic move on i was raised um as
you know i felt like i was a very proud
secular humanist and i was you know
maybe a little bit of a situational
emphasis but whatever um i um but after
you know like a dozen years together
after having some kids
um we or one kid at the time we ended up
having three boys but at the time one i
i realized i really um
uh
drew a lot of
um
i don't know energy
um
from
the rituals from the
philosophy
from the thinking from the
thoughtfulness of judaism and so one day
i literally said to my husband over
breakfast like i think i'm gonna convert
and he literally did one of these like
what you know
and um
and what was great is we spent a year
going to like introduction to judaism
classes together
and um
and we had talked we talked about things
that we've never talked about in the
dozen years we've been together right
and and that was what was so enriching
and in an interesting way it changed his
view of his own judaism because
the rabbi went from the guy up on the
bema to the guy sitting next to us
chatting about the yankees right and so
that changed his perspective too and and
for me we've you know been part of the
lay leadership in the congregation our
kids are very identified very strongly
as both jews and korean americans um
the joke in our house is that they're 50
korean and 100 jewish um and
and uh and so it's been an incredible
source of
um
strength and
um and
family and love you know like we just
last week i i hosted two seders you know
and i i make a pretty good latka and
you're welcome to come next time and you
know um my motzball soup even though the
moth balls are from a box are still
pretty good it works that still works
yeah it still works it's really i i cut
some corners here and there but it's um
it's really part of our family tradition
but i also make you know dumplings from
scratch and rice cake soup for you know
new year's day and and so i feel like my
faith is something that i
um
literally was literally was an act of
faith uh to decide that i wanted to be
uh be a jew
and and and and live as one right like
yeah
does that shape to your perspective in
your work after that
conversion so
absolutely i mean you know it it kind of
dovetails because you know at the seder
every year we talk about um treating
strange strangers uh you know
remembering to to be kind to strangers
because you were one stranger in a
strange land to understand that
oppression everywhere is anywhere is is
uh something that jews stand up against
right and it's so interesting the
interweaving like right now i told you
the story about the adl and the aapi
community and i talk often about how
frederick douglass spoke out against the
chinese exclusion act
you know back
at the time in the 1880s and
you know how the jews worked in the
civil rights you know uh
fear and in that
in that historical you know brotherhood
really and and that is something that i
wish
was
a better understood yeah you know
um than the
things that i see right now especially
online where um hate gets clicks
and there's a lot of anti this anti that
you know you're
you know stepping out you're this and
there's this like you know don't compare
your pain to my pain like there's a lot
of
animosity when there's really
a lot of shared history and shared um
shared goals really you know and so
so
yes that's been a large part of my faith
journey and it's informed you know all
of it in in different ways yeah very
encouraging to hear and there's great
perspective as well i mean both your
journey and the story that you shared of
the individual just that aspect of grace
and forgiveness
i know
you know tremendous
well thank you so much we've covered a
lot of different topics i really enjoy
just having this free-flowing
conversation and just again all the work
that you've done to bring so many
important stories to life into larger
audiences and hopefully to help us move
forward as a society to a better place
as well definitely appreciate you taking
the time to be here to share a little
bit about your journey and about the
path that you place the ways that you're
speaking up on behalf of so many thank
you so much for taking time to be here
on the eddie hour
thank you dr addie and i am a huge fan
of your work and want to dig into it so
maybe someday i could interview you that
would be wonderful
thank you so much i i appreciate the uh
the investment and i may take you up on
that offer as well i think our listeners
would definitely enjoy that
i know they would
excellent thanks so much
all right bye
[Music]